on m'a bonsoir à tous je suis ravi
d'être ce soir avec vous en effet on va
parler de commerce alimentaire je sais
quand on entend le mot commerce
alimentaire voilà le mot commerce tout
de suite ça grince un peu aux oreilles
mais on va quand même parler de commerce
alimentaire et on va essayer de voir
comment est-ce que ce commerce
alimentaire il contribue finalement à
l'évolution sociale
comment même d'une certaine manière le
commerce alimentaire devrait être peut
être reconnue d'utilité publique
donc on va le faire de manière très
simple est ce que je voulais commencer à
faire avec vous c'est un petit jeu tout
de suite pour vous mettre dans
l'ambiance on est en fin de journée donc
j'ai préparé un petit jeu de devinettes
vous allez voir pourquoi parce que quand
on parle de commerce alimentaire on
parle d'aliments quand on parle
d'aliments bien sûr on va parler de
fruits et quand on parle de fruits j'ai
prévu et préparé un jeu de fruits voilà
alors ce jeu de fruits vous allez voir
il ya trois images qui vont venir les
unes derrière les autres derrière moi et
vous vous allez devoir deviner quel est
ce fruit je vous dis tout de suite le
premier j'ai pris un fruit facile parce
que vous êtes en fin de journée tout ça
et je veux que vous participiez vous
soyez vraiment dans l'ambiance
donc j'ai pris un fruit cool normalement
vous devriez le trouver d'accord après
l'autre ils un peu plus difficile vous
êtes prêts voilà ça alors c'est quoi
au fur et ça c'est bon c'est nickel
attention jean sort un deuxième un peu
plus compliqué ça va monter en gamme
attention vous êtes prêts ah ouais bien
à oui je vois qu'on a des choix que vous
êtes aux artichauts
donc là je sors un fruit qui devrait
entre guillemets normalement calmer
l'assistance
ah ouais ah vous êtes bon voilà vous
êtes quand même assez fort alors vous
voyez ce qui est assez marrant dans
l'est dans les temps dans le petit
exemple et petit exercice convient de
faire c'est que si j'avais posé la même
question dans la même salle il ya 70 ans
aucun d'entre nous auraient pu
reconnaître ce fruit c'est un truc de
fou
comment se fait-il que il ya 70 ans
personne n'aurait pu reconnaître ses
fruits d'accord alors simplement c'est
pas long à 70 ans et
tout juste une petite génération donc
normalement alors la question qu'on peut
se poser c'est de se dire mais comment
est-ce que ce commerce alimentaire qui
est finalement cette culture du commerce
alimentaire je rappelle quand même juste
que c'est en france 200 milliards
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires et un peu
moins d'un million de salariés
comment se fait-il que ce commerce
alimentaire ils soient maintenant
partagée par tous et sue et surtout
accessible à tous alors je vous
expliquais s'est passé pourquoi c'est
parce que en fait ici ici là dans ce
champ de betteraves que vous voyez
derrière moi eh bien il ya 70 ans
il ya des dingues qu'on imaginait faire
ça de fou on était là et eux ils ont dit
bah allez ici ça va être génial on va
faire ça d'accord alors ça y est je vous
vois déjà un peu les regards suspicieux
en vous disant ouhlala celui ci va nous
refaire la retape de du secteur va se
transformer en vrp la grande
distribution
je vous le dis tout de suite on va pas
parler de grande distribution là on va
parler de commerce parce que le commerce
que vous allez voir si une valeur noble
et au travers de ce commerce je vais pas
vous parler de l'histoire du commerce
avec un grand h non là ce que je vais
faire avec vous c'est qu'on a parlé des
petites histoires des grands commerçants
déjà l'uso les boucicaut des leclerc des
mulliez et le rock
tous ces gens là qui sont à la fois des
sonorités dans vos oreilles mais dont
parfois vous ne connaissez pas le génie
la première innovation que je voudrais
partager avec vous et je la trouve assez
génial vous allez voir la photo parle
d'elle même de toutes les façons vous
allez voir c'est ça ça c'est une
innovation de dengue ou ici c'est une
innovation de dengue allons mais pas les
bouteilles de vin dans un an juste
d'avoir le pris à côté du produit ça il
ya 70 ans je vous dis tout de suite ça
n'existait pas quand vous faisiez vos
courses il ya 70 ans
d'abord
vous n'acceptez pas au magasin comme ça
vous étiez autorisées à rentrer chez le
commerçant d'accord qui sélectionnaient
qui rentrait chez lui
et puis quand vous arriviez là vous
tombiez sur un comptoir avec un
commerçant en blouse blanche crayon gris
sur l'oreille et là il se passer un truc
absolument incroyable il y avait une
sorte de duel entre le commerçant et le
client parce que le jeu du commerçant à
l'époque c'était de savoir combien vous
vous pouviez m donc résultat des courses
qu'est ce qui se passait et bien rentré
dans un magasin beaux souliers bien
peignés chose costume neuf et là c'était
entre trois et quatre fois le prix vous
rentriez chaussures crottées en
guenilles et là c'était moins 30%
voyez comme quoi des petites innovations
font des grandes révolutions
la deuxième innovation ces grands
commerçants c'est celle ci ça c'est une
innovation de tincques
j'adore ça là non mais pour vous oui je
comprends mais je vais vous expliquer ce
qui se passe en fait simplement cet
enfant elle est en train de manger avec
une totale insouciance
alors ça il ya soixante dix ans n'était
pas possible parce que quand vous
faisiez vos courses alimentaires il ya
70 ans
d'abord vous aviez vous inspecté de
manière très méticuleuse chaque aliment
à l'époque il ya 70 ans il y avait
quinze mille décès par an d'intoxication
alimentaire d'accord aujourd'hui on est
à 150
alors bien sûr on a comme nous l'a
expliqué sylvia les progrès du packaging
aussi le réfrigérateur qui est arrivé
qui a changé quand même beaucoup de
choses et puis l'éducation qui a
beaucoup aidé à faire en sorte que les
aliments puissent être maintenant on
puisse se nourrir s'en soucier mais ce
qu'on a oublié c'est que la
quasi-totalité des normes alimentaires
en allant de l'extraction du producteur
jusqu'à la mise mise à disposition du
consommateur ont été au taux imposé par
ces grands commerçants c'est ni l'état
ni les règles et les normes c'est eux
mêmes qui ont anticipé la quasi totalité
de ces normes alimentaires
alors la troisième innovation que je
vais partager avec vous hélas assez
incroyable c'est celle ci encore un
petit peu d'étonnement dans le regard
mais celle ci j'y crois beaucoup en fait
qu'est ce qu'on voit en voit un couple
de retraités qui finalement après 40 45
ans de labeur sont en train de profiter
d'une d'une deuxième partie de vie bien
mérité je crois qu'on est assez tôt
nombreux à savoir qu'en effet c'est un
grand commerçant qui a eu l'idée de
créer avant l'état avant la caisse de
retraite des cheminots avant la caisse
de retraite des des mineurs il a eu
l'idée de créer la première caisse de
retraite de ses salariés
c'est lui qui a imaginé ce grand
commerçant de dire un temps on ne peut
pas se séparer nos salariés les laisser
sur le bord de la route
même mieux que ça je vais vous dire
savez vous que la sécurité sociale
oui notre sécurité sociale elle n'a pas
été inventé par un médecin n'a pas été
inventé par l'état non elle a été
inventée par un grand commerçant qui
avait créé la caisse de solidarité des
salariés du printemps à ça vous en
bouche un coin je peux comprendre un
mais mais néanmoins on a derrière ces
éléments de grands commerçants
alors vous vous dites mais il est là il
nous explique la vocation sociale de ces
grands commerçants et surtout leur
vision sociale ce que j'essaye de
partager avec vous cette vous dire qu'il
n'ya pas de grands commerçants d'abord
commencé par une vision de la société
une vision des gens une vision qu'on
peut partager alors certains d'entre
vous vont me dire oui mais tu es gentil
rodolphe en fait c'est pas dans ce sens
là que ça marche n'a rien compris
en réalité ces gars là ils ont une
vision sociale pour le pognon et oui
pour l'argent ils font ça parce qu'ils
ont envie de récupérer de l'argent alors
l'argent on va en parler parce que je me
suis posé la question
finalement c'est vrai peut-être qu'ils
le font pour l'argent
le bénéfice on va en parler il ya 4 5
ans de cela j'ai décidé d'aller en
magasin comme on dit en sortie de caisse
et j'ai passé
grosse journée a interrogé une
cinquantaine de clients consommateurs
comme vous et moi qui sortais avec leurs
courses et je leur posais une question
hyper simples gens disaient à votre avis
ici là combien c'est quoi la marge du
commerçant la marge nette qu'est ce qui
lui reste à la fin en pourcentage
eh bien figurez-vous que de ces
cinquante personnes
le pourcentage le plus faible que j'ai
recueillis c'est 30 % est le plus élevé
c'est sa grande pour cent je me suis dit
maintenant bon sens la marche du
commerce ans arrive à akwa caisse est
impeccable
après j'ai creusé j'ai regardé je vais
partager avec vous c'est quoi la marge
réelle d'un commerçant la commerçants
alimentaires
ça marche ah oui mince je voulais vous
parler d'un truc vous en parlait dans
deux zones
c'est quoi la commère la marche de ces
commerçants alimentaires la marge d'un
commerçant alimentaire c'est 1,4 pour
cent 1,4 par an ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que sur un panier de courses
de 50 euros ce qui reste à la fin pour
le commerçant c'est 70 centimes et
croyez moi que pour avoir 70 centimes à
la fin sur 50 euros c'est du sport alors
oui c'est vrai c'est sur un gros volume
c'est sur un gros volume je suis
d'accord mais quand ça perd ça perd gros
je vous le garantis alors la question je
me suis posée et qui m'anime tous les
jours je veux non mais pourquoi bon sens
après ces innovations après ces
visionnaires après 7,7 socialisation
finalement de ce commerce alimentaire
qui a quand même changé nos vies on va
en parler mais pourquoi on est tous là
et qu'on est totalement émerveillé par
sa ça ça nous émerveille leur histoire
leurs profits change la vie etc etc on
n'arrive pas à être émerveillé par sa
non de dollars d'accords comment ça se
fait bon sens alors là cet élément là la
question qu'on peut se poser après
avoir vu tout ça c'est comment est-ce
qu'on peut réconcilier cette grande
histoire commerciale avec tous ces
consommateurs et donc comment ça va se
passer dans les dix vingt trente
prochaines années comment est-ce qu'on
peut changer cette histoire commence
qu'on peut changer cette alchimie
comment cet élément de reconnaissance il
peut venir un peu se marier voyez un peu
comme george tout à l'heure qui nous
paraît du champignon ne sais pas si vous
vous souvenez qu'est la liaison de tous
de toute l'humanité là et bien moi je
pense que le commerce c'est aussi une
forme de champignon social d'accord et
donc je me suis dit mais comment ça va
évoluer
la première chose qui est un point
auquel je crois énormément c'est qu'il
va falloir qu'on se sépare de termes
grande distribution ça c'est pas bon du
tout c'est pas grande qui me gêne c'est
distribution distribution ça va pas ça
me plaît pas et donc en réfléchissant à
comment s'en séparer je suis remonté un
petit peu en arrière et je suis remonté
à l'origine du terme distribution est en
fait le terme distribution ça vient du
14e siècle
en treize 109 exactement et en fait ça
vient d'un mot d'une fonction sociale de
l'époque terre de gens qui avaient un
métier qu'on appelait les distributeurs
qu'est ce que c'était que les
distributeurs
c'était des gens dont le métier était de
s'occuper des autres c'est pour ça que
pendant des siècles le mot distribution
il a voulu dire contribution c'était
vraiment un mot équivalent à
contribution donc peut-être qu'on
pourrait se poser la question de se dire
est ce que demain la grande distribution
pourrait pas devenir un grand
contributeur une grande contribution une
grande contribution sociale
la deuxième conviction j'avance voilà la
deuxième condition à laquelle je crois
énormément c'est que on connait tous ce
terme de fracture numérique avec d'un
côté ceux qui ont accès au digital
et puis ce qu'ils n'y ont pas accès et
bien moi je crois qu'il existe encore
dans le monde une fracture commerçante
avec ceux qui ont accès à cette forme de
commerce et ceux qui n'y ont pas accès
et que finalement on a vite oublié le
fait que aujourd'hui dans nos sociétés
tous ensemble d'accord on évolue sans se
soucier des problématiques de nos
besoins primaires mais il existe des
régions dans le monde entière ou des
populations ne pense qu'à une seule
chose comment se nourrir boire ou manger
et donc par rapport à ça je suis
intimement convaincu je ressens vraiment
que cette fracture commerçante elle va
se diminuer et que ce commerce
il doit irriguer et ça c'est un point
important parce que j'allais vous je
voulais vous poser une question
d'ailleurs mais je pense que je vais
avoir zéro réponse là dessus parce que
si je me si je dis qui est chasseur
cueilleur ou pêcheurs dans la salle et
qui vide ça et qui nourrit sa famille
avec ça ça n'existe plus mais il ya
encore des régions qui existe là dessus
et donc je pense que dans les 20 à 30
prochaines années
cette fracture commerçante elle va
vraiment se réduire elle va se réduire
elle va permettre à tout un tas de
population de se libérer d'un certain
nombre de contingence matérielle du
moins de contingence il ya des besoins
primaires pour pouvoir développer leur
créativité
le dernier élément que je veux partager
on en a beaucoup parlé aujourd'hui ça
m'a fait énormément plaisir non pas pour
mon ego mais de me dire que finalement
les gens très intelligents arrive à
projeter des choses de là dessus c'est
que je crois que les 50 dernières années
qu'on vient de se dérouler les 70
dernières années qui viennent de se
passer on a tous évolué dans le commerce
alimentaire de masse c'est vraiment
l'alimentation pour tous à tous les
instants à tous les moments crois qu'on
est en train de basculer dans un monde
on est en train de considérer que ça
c'est un acquis d'accord et qu'on est en
train de basculer dans le commerce
alimentaire de sens et ça c'est capital
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
aujourd'hui de plus en plus la manière
dont nous consommons nous définit c'est
à dire que consommer c'est plus acquérir
et accumulé consommer c'est partager des
valeurs c'est finalement on voit très
très bien tout ce que ça veut dire
derrière ça ça veut dire que finalement
aujourd'hui on a un sens très
résidus du fait que dès qu'on achète
quelque chose c'est une part de notre
travail c'est une part de notre temps
c'est une part de nos croyances qui est
en train de basculer de transporter dans
ce produit est particulièrement dans
l'alimentation
donc c'est vrai qu'avec une consommation
de sens et finalement un commerce de
sens on va se rendre compte que les
changes commercial sera dans les années
à venir
un échange de valeur de croyance c'est
quasiment religieux et on en a beaucoup
parlé aujourd'hui donc vous connaissez
tous le fameux kobe tôt ergo soum le je
pense donc je suis bien je crois que
demain nous allons passe pas de passer
dans le jeu consomme donc je suis
pourquoi parce que c'est en effet la
manière dont on va acheter la manière
dont on va consommer la manière dont on
va se comporter vis-à-vis de nos
éléments qui vont définir l'ensemble de
l'univers de nos valeurs voilà merci à
tous